u.s officials are warning about
potential cyber attacks from russia as
the war in ukraine drags on they say
everything from the public transit
systems to banks and the energy sector
could be targeted in this country senior
investigator correspondent catherine
herridge has
more with the russian invasion of
ukraine in its eighth week a top u.s
cyber security official told 60 minutes
vladimir putin may resort to digital
warfare against american targets we are
seeing evolving intelligence about
russian planning for potential attacks
and we have to assume that there's going
to be a breach there's going to be an
incident there's going to be an attack a
march fbi alert obtained by cbs news
warned of increased reconnaissance by
foreign actors of u.s energy networks
searching for vulnerabilities and in
recent weeks the us government's shields
up campaign said every organization
large and small must be prepared to
respond to disruptive cyber incidents
think about energy companies financial
services sector transportation or
communication key organizations that are
part of our day-to-day lives sean henry
is the cso and president of services at
cyber security firm crowdstrike if they
were shut down for weeks or months with
the inability to service their their
consumers that would be catastrophic to
the united states so you're saying
you go to the atm the atm is not working
you try and get on public transit and
the trains are not running
that is exactly what i'm saying the
justice department recently unsealed
criminal charges for russian hackers
alleging a pass campaign against the
energy sector that targeted victims in
the united states and in more than 135
other countries it is very much the type
of activity that we are warning about
today when it comes to russia's response
to the world's response to the horror in
ukraine why do you think russia has not
unleashed
a major cyber attack at this point um i
think that it's
an arrow in their quiver i think that
there may be some concern about what
might happen in a retaliatory response
and cyber security experts tell cbs news
the u.s has a robust capability to
respond but there can be unintended
consequences and the risk of further
escalation with potentially damaging
fallout for all involved gail
all right catherine thank you very much